ah
[Música]
aquí en marruecos la homosexualidad se
castiga hasta con tres años de cárcel y
este marco legal propicia cierta
normalización hacia las agresiones
contra la comunidad lgtb y fue sonado el
caso de una influencer que en pleno
confinamiento en 2020 incitó a sus
seguidores a trapear usuarios en las
redes sociales de la comunidad lgtb y
para desvelar sus identidades en
facebook pero por otra parte también
existe un creciente movimiento social
muy fuerte en las redes que defiende los
derechos de la comunidad lgtb y más allá
también ha tomado mucha fuerza la
plataforma fuera de la ley que exige la
derogación de todas las leyes morales
del código penal que prohíbe nada desde
el aborto hasta el sexo fuera del
matrimonio la homosexualidad entre otras
cuestiones fundamentales y cuyo
incumplimiento lleva a la cárcel a miles
de personas cada año y por otra parte
cabe tener en cuenta que aunque muchos
discursos oficiales atribuyen estas
leyes morales al islam religión de
estado en marruecos lo cierto es que
datan del código napoleónico del siglo
19 impuesto durante la colonización
francesa y plasmado en la constitución
tras la independencia del país
[Música]
contrariamente a lo que podría esperarse
el gobierno de jair bolsonaro no ha
adoptado políticas activas contra el
colectivo lgtb y se estima que en brasil
20 millones de personas es decir el 10%
de la población pertenecen a este
colectivo hace dos años la corte suprema
que analizó la homofobia y la transfobia
sin embargo brasil sigue siendo el país
que más mata trans en el mundo el año
pasado fueron 175 es decir uno cada dos
días recientemente en la ciudad de
recife una mujer trans tuvo el cuerpo
quemado en un 40% por un adolescente un
caso que ha conmocionado el país pero
curiosamente vemos que también la
representación de trans en las cámaras
municipales y en el parlamento sigue
aumentando en las elecciones municipales
del año pasado 30 candidatas trans
resultaron elegidas
[Música]
si hablamos de retos para la comunidad
lgtb y en egipto está absolutamente todo
por hacer no hay ninguna ley que lo
prohíba específicamente pero si hay
muchas leyes que hablan de inmoralidad o
de atentar contra los derechos de la
familia y es precisamente de esas leyes
de las que se vale la autoridad egipcia
para reprimir a todos aquellos
individuos que forman parte de esa
comunidad o se atreven a querer y sentir
diferente el ejemplo más claro hace
cuatro años fue durante el concierto del
grupo libanés más rue leila en el que
algunos jóvenes egipcios decidieron
esgrimir una bandera arcoiris y
reivindicar su sexualidad muchos
acabaron detenidos y entre ellos sarah
hijazi una activista y escritora egipcia
lesbiana que pasó tres meses en la
cárcel siendo torturada y abusada tiempo
después ya en el exilio acabaría su vida
con una carta en la cual perdonaba y se
convertiría no solamente en un símbolo
dentro del país sino dentro de la
comunidad internacional de esa lucha en
la que todavía queda tanto por hacer en
los derechos y libertades de la
comunidad lgtb
[Música]